Dominic Cummings had little to say to
journalists outside his home on Sunday
it's alleged the Prime Minister's chief
adviser broke lockdown rules travelling
hundreds of kilometers to Durham in
northeast England to his parents estate
and the height of restrictions in March
and if things weren't awkward enough for
Cummings cue the arrival of a protest
van with a reminder of Boyce Johnson's
address to the nation to stay at home
you must stay at home cummings said the
trip was to ensure his four-year-old son
was looked after because his wife was
suffering from coronavirus symptoms
something he would also develop he said
he remained in isolation in a separate
property on his parents estate but
eyewitnesses claimed Cummings left
lockdown to visit a nearby beauty spot
and that he made another trip to the
northeast after returning to London in
April allegations the Prime Minister was
quick to dismiss at an unscheduled
appearance at the daily Downing Street
coronavirus briefing there have been
many other allegations about what
happened when he was in self isolation
and thereafter some of them palpably
false I believe that in every respect
he is acted responsibly and legally and
with integrity despite support from the
top cummings face is a storm of
criticism from figures in the police
health service and scientific community
some MPs in his own party want him to
quit I think his position is untenable
it's because of Dominic's slogans around
these rules that mums and dads grannies
and grandpas across the country will
have felt that they had to stay at home
if Kovac got into their families and of
course they too care about their
children but they knew they had they
must stay at home for seven days for the
first person 14 days for the others and
and now it turns out they could have
been driving around the country with
symptoms this isn't just a story about
one man this is about faith in a
government that sets rules and
regulations demanding self-discipline
and sacrifice of people stopping the
spread of the virus is meant to be a
collective endeavor no exceptions
Dominic Cummings is one of the most
divisive figures in British politics the
mastermind behind the campaign to leave
the EU who together with Boris Johnson
plotted to revolutionize British
politics
he's a non elected official but wields
more power and influence than many
people are comfortable with opposition
MPs are now calling for a full inquiry
into all of the allegations against
Cummings at a time when trust in
government has rarely been needed more
neve barker al jazeera
westminster